Trascrizione: Valentina Liguori
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Che cosa ci spinge ad imparare?
Io mi sono fatto
questa domanda molto spesso.
Me lo chiedevo sempre
quando mi sentivo dire:
"È bravo, ma non si applica".
Quanti di voi si sono sentiti dire:
"Bravo, ma non si applica?"
Beh, sono in buona compagnia.
Ricordo ancora le parole
della professoressa di inglese del liceo,
una donna tutta d'un pezzo,
con l'accento british
anche quando parlava in italiano:
"Impegnati, un giorno
l'inglese ti servirà.
È fondamentale, per il mondo del lavoro".
Ma lo stimolo non arrivava,
e io preferivo passare i miei pomeriggi
a fare qualche videogioco strano,
piuttosto che studiare.
Ovviamente, per la fine del liceo
il mio livello di inglese
era semplicemente pessimo.
Poi, inizio l'università.
Mi trovo in un ambiente internazionale,
e per paura di sentirmi escluso
iniziano le prime incertezze.
Forse, la professoressa
del liceo aveva ragione!
Decido quindi di rischiare:
Inizio a cercare un'opportunità
di lavoro all'estero;
e nel giro di qualche settimana
sono a Vancouver, in Canada,
a fare uno stage
durante le Olimpiadi invernali.
Questo sono io.
Ero più giovane, sicuramente più elegante,
ma il mio livello d'inglese
era ancora pessimo.
E all'inizio è stato sfidante:
avevo paura di parlare,
facevo fatica ad apprendere.
E questo mi ha messo
in uno stato di crisi,
uno stato di crisi interno.
Quando provavo a parlare, facevo fatica;
quando mi parlavano,
facevo finta di capire
ma in realtà non capivo.
Poi ho pensato:
sono a 10.000 chilometri
di distanza da casa,
in un posto incredibile,
con della gente pazzesca.
Di cosa dovrei aver paura?
Ed ecco che scatta qualcosa:
questa paura si trasforma in sfida.
Una sfida, proprio come quelle
dei videogiochi che mi piacevano tanto.
E nel giro di qualche
giorno, mi rendo conto
che il processo di apprendimento
sarà tutto in discesa.
Inizio perfino a sognare, in inglese:
la dimostrazione che mi ero sbloccato.
Concludo il mio percorso
di studi universitari
scrivendo e discutendo la tesi in inglese.
Alla fine, mi ero applicato.
Ma perché non mi sono applicato prima?
È possibile che, in scenari di incertezza,
abbiamo maggiori incentivi ad imparare?
Questa domanda, per me,
è diventata quasi un'ossessione.
E da questa ossessione,
sei anni fa, insieme a degli amici
abbiamo creato una scuola online.
L'obiettivo era semplice, e ambizioso:
creare una scuola di competenze digitali
che incentivasse l'apprendimento.
Questi siamo noi, a Berlino,
nella mia cameretta,
mentre stiamo creando
le fondamenta di questa scuola.
Sei anni dopo, abbiamo
più di 80.000 studenti;
e ogni giorno ci impegniamo
a migliorare, a fare formazione.
Recentemente, ho trovato uno studio
dell'Università di Yale.
Questo studio di neuroscienza
dimostra che abbiamo
una maggiore attività cerebrale
quando siamo in un contesto di incertezza,
mentre abbiamo minore attività cerebrale
quando la situazione
è semplice da prevedere.
La conferma, quindi, mi arriva
proprio dalla scienza, dalla neuroscienza.
È nell'incertezza, che abbiamo
maggiori incentivi ad imparare.
E tutti noi ci troviamo
ad imparare, nella nostra vita.
A volte lo facciamo più volte,
nel corso di una vita.
Lo facciamo perché ci obbligano;
lo facciamo perché vogliamo migliorare,
o crescere il nostro lavoro;
lo facciamo perché siamo curiosi,
e abbiamo tantissimi
incentivi, nell'imparare.
E io ho notato una cosa:
quando impariamo, seguiamo tutti
un percorso simile, simile a tutti noi.
L'ho provato in primis sulla mia pelle;
e l'ho scoperto, anche,
dall'esperienza dei nostri studenti.
Questo processo è composto da tre fasi.
Fase uno: la scintilla.
In questa fase siamo
in un contesto di incertezza.
Incertezza interna -  siamo insicuri,
vogliamo imparare qualcosa, siamo curiosi-
oppure da un'incertezza esterna.
L'ambiente che ci circonda, l'ecosistema,
ci spingono a voler imparare
qualcosa di nuovo.
Perché la scintilla è proprio questo:
è un incentivo che ci fa
scattare un desiderio.
Il desiderio di imparare,
imparare una nuova competenza.
È successo anche a me.
Io lavoravo in una banca di investimento.
Il lavoro mi piaceva:
era il percorso perfetto
per la mia carriera.
Ma sentivo la necessità,
e il bisogno, di un nuovo stimolo.
Ero anche molto appassionato
del mondo digitale.
Ed ecco che arriva la mia scintilla.
John, il mio amico John, mi incuriosisce
parlandomi di programmazione.
Ormai sono incuriosito,
mi vedo già come un programmatore.
Ed ecco che sono nella fase due.
Fase due: la ricerca.
In questa fase ormai siamo incuriositi,
sappiamo che vogliamo imparare
qualcosa di nuovo;
e si attiva il nostro lato nerd.
Andiamo su Google, scriviamo
"Come imparare a -".
iniziamo a leggere dei libri;
iniziamo a studiare.
Anch'io l'ho fatto:
ho iniziato a visitare i blog,
vedere centinaia di video online.
Ne ho perfino visto uno, di 28 minuti,
in cui si paragonava l'evoluzione
dei linguaggi di programmazione
all'evoluzione della specie umana.
Sì, ero curioso:
in questa fase siamo curiosi,
siamo pieni di energia,
stiamo imparando,
apprendiamo concetti nuovi
e siamo motivati.
Tutto sembra andare per il verso giusto;
ma ecco che arriva la fase tre.
Crisi.
In questa fase abbiamo
le prime difficoltà.
Soprattutto, avviene
quando iniziamo a mettere in pratica
quello che stiamo imparando.
Iniziamo ad avere i primi dubbi,
e questi dubbi fanno scattare in noi
lo stato di crisi interno.
Questo stato di crisi
ci porta ad avere paura,
paura di sbagliare.
Ci sono passato anch'io.
Ho pensato - stavo imparando
a programmare.
Prima difficoltà: cosa ho pensato?
"Forse non fa per me".
Quante volte, nella vita, pensiamo:
"Forse non fa per me"?
Ci passano tutti,
ci passano anche i nostri studenti,
e lo vediamo spesso anche su di loro.
Passiamo tutti da questo stato di crisi.
Crisi, dal greco, significa:
"scelta, decisione".
Infatti, il successo della nostra
esperienza di apprendimento
è dato proprio dalla scelta
di come decidiamo
di approcciare questa fase.
E io come l'ho approciata?
Così come quando ho imparato inglese:
mi sono trovato una sfida,
una sfida come quella dei videogiochi
che mi piacevano tanto al liceo,
quando non volevo studiare.
Ho deciso di realizzare
il sito di un ristorante,
in cambio di qualche cena.
Nel giro di una settimana,
e qualche notte insonne,
il sito era online.
E anche se non sembra
era questo, ed era perfetto.
Ok, no: non era perfetto.
Era pieno di bug,
dal telefono si leggeva male,
ed era perfino lento a caricarsi.
Ma per me era perfetto,
perché mi aveva dimostrato
che potevo diventare un programmatore.
E questo processo lo vediamo, spesso,
anche sui nostri studenti.
Ad esempio, cerchiamo di incentivarli
a mettere in pratica subito
quello che stanno imparando,
a non aver paura di sbagliare.
Buttati.
Mettiti in gioco.
Scopri il suo stato di crisi.
Questo è quello che cerchiamo di passare.
E questo processo di apprendimento
funziona quando vogliamo imparare
delle nuove competenze.
E se ci pensate bene,
crescere non è un percorso
di apprendimento continuo?
Un'immagine di questo processo di crescita
potrebbe essere questa:
quelli in bici siamo noi,
la bandierina è il nostro obiettivo,
e quello in alto solitamente
è quello che ci immaginiamo,
quello che vorremmo che sia
il nostro processo di crescita.
Abbiamo un obiettivo, cerchiamo
di raggiungerlo in maniera lineare,
cresciamo in maniera
piuttosto prevedibile.
La realtà, però - siamo nel grafico sotto.
Provate a pensare quando avete, appunto,
imparato qualcosa di nuovo,
alla relazione con un vostro partner,
con degli amici
o quando vi siete, anche,
approcciati ad uno sport.
Probabilmente, non è stato
un processo di crescita lineare:
ma è stato un processo
fatto di alti e bassi.
Come delle montagne russe,
proprio come il grafico sotto.
E sapete cosa mi ricorda?
Mi ricorda uno di quei videogiochi
che mi piaceva tantissimo
quando ero ragazzino,
quando ero al liceo e non volevo studiare.
Io non avrei mai giocato a quello sopra:
noioso, poco sfidante,
nessuno vorrebbe farlo.
Quello sotto, invece,
sembra divertente e sfidante.
Bisogna attraversare dei massi,
attraversare un ponte
che rischia di crollare,
costruirsi una barca, imparare a navigare,
superare una tempesta -
e forse, arrivare alla bandierina.
Questo è sfidante.
E la vita, se ci pensate bene, è questo:
è un processo di crescita
dove abbiamo delle difficoltà,
delle sfide, e delle crisi.
Ma possiamo eliminare le crisi?
Conoscete la storia del cigno nero?
Il cigno nero -
fino al 1700, nell'emisfero
dove siamo noi, quello boreale,
si credeva che il cigno nero
non esistesse.
Poi si scopre l'Australia:
e un esploratore olandese,
durante una delle sue esplorazioni,
vede per la prima volta un cigno nero:
il cigno nero esiste!
Questo ci dimostra che quello
che crediamo sia impossibile,
in realtà può essere
smentito successivamente.
Il cigno nero è diventato una metafora
per indicare un evento che:
è difficile da prevedere;
ha effetti rilevanti;
e può essere razionalizzato a posteriori.
E le crisi, ad oggi, utilizzano
la metafora del cigno nero.
Quando vogliamo parlare di una crisi,
diciamo che è un cigno nero.
Proprio perché è difficile da prevedere,
ha un impatto,
e a posteriori viene razionalizzata.
La storia del Cigno nero
ci insegna che le crisi esistono,
e sono una parte integrante
della nostra vita.
E invece di eliminarle,
dovremmo provare a vederle
come delle sfide.
Delle sfide che ci danno
l'opportunità di crescere.
Delle sfide dove
questi momenti di difficoltà
possono diventare delle occasioni
di crescita, e di apprendimento.
Quindi, per tornare alla domanda iniziale,
che cosa ci spinge ad imparare?
Tutto parte da una scintilla,
che ci spinge alla ricerca.
Ma il vero momento che ci porta a crescere
è la crisi.
Infatti,
è l'incertezza che ci spinge ad imparare;
ma è la crisi
che stimola il nostro cervello
ad apprendere realmente.
Quale prossima crisi può diventare
la tua opportunità di crescita?
(Applausi)